il faut aller jouer dehors plus souvent
être plus souvent dehors oui vous
pourriez construire des choses vous
prouviez construire un fort dans le
jardin oui c'est bien fort comme ça tu
as vitré toutes tes copines un fort dans
le jardin mais qu'est-ce que j'en ferais
et vous pourrez jouer quoi dans un fort
attend à ton âge en avait des maisons en
hauteur on joue avec des tiges de
noisetiers des actes en plus personne ne
joue avec du noisetier pourriez jouer à
la marchande
oui et puis aux osselets à chercher des
cadavres aux égarés c'était vrai jeu ça
s'est super je t'assure tu fais rouler
une roue de vélo avec un bateau et tu
pourras côté c'est fini ce temps là on
est au 21ème siècle peut vivre sans
technologie wi de technologie charlotte
pause ça